LIFE.
IF THAT IS OPENING NEW DOORS TO
TREATMENT OPTIONS AND VACCINE
EFFORTS AROUND THE WORLD.
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT FROM THE NORTH LAWN.
>> IN THE FACE OF CONTINUED
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY, THE
WHITE HOUSE IS CONSIDERING MORE
BOLD MOVES INCLUDING POSSIBLY
TAKING AN EQUITY STAKE IN LARGE
CORPORATIONS, POSSIBLY COVERING
REVENUES FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
ON THE HEALTH FRONT TODAY, THERE
WERE MORE BOLD MOVES AS WELL.
>> THE PRESIDENT CALLED IN THE
CAVALRY DIRECT TO THE MILITARY
TO SEND THE HOSPITAL SHIP
COMFORT TO NEW YORK HARBOR AND
MERCY TO THE THE WEST COAST.
>> A THING LIKE THIS HAS NEVER
BEEN REQUESTED, WE NEED
RESPIRATORS, WE NEED
VENTILATORS, IT’S A COMPLEX
PIECE OF EQUIPMENT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF VENTILATORS BUT
WE ARE GOING TO BE ORDERING
THEM.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE WAS
AUTHORIZING THE ACT, EARLIER
SENATE MINORITY LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER URGED HIM TO USE
IT AND USE IT NOW.
>> WE KNOW IN TWO WEEKS THE
NUMBER OF VENTILATORS MIGHT
BECOME A MASSIVE PROBLEM.
WE MUST GET AHEAD OF IT NOW.
>> THE BILL IS PASSED.
>> AS THE SENATE MOVE TO PASS
THE HOUSE BILL ON TESTING, PAID
LEAVE, AND UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE THE TREASURY SECRETARY
SAID THE NEXT PHASE OF FISCAL
STIMULUS COULD TOP
$1.3 TRILLION.
THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT WILL BE
SENDING OUT CHECKS IN TWO
TRANCHES WORTH $250 BILLION
APIECE, THE FIRST ON APRIL 6TH
AND THE SECOND ON MAY 18TH.
THE SIZE OF THE INDIVIDUAL
CHECKS STILL UNKNOWN.
>> HASN’T BEEN DETERMINED YET
BUT IT WILL SHORTLY BE
DETERMINED AND PEOPLE WANT TO GO
BIG.
EVERYONE WANTS TO GO BIG.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAYING AMERICA
IS ON A WARTIME FOOTING.
>> I’M IN A SENSE A WARTIME
PRESIDENT, THAT’S WHAT WE ARE
FIGHTING.
>> NEW DATA OUT OF FRANCE AND
ITALY SHOWS A TROUBLING INCREASE
IN SERIOUS ILLNESS AMONG YOUNGER
PEOPLE WHO WERE ASSUMED TO HAVE
A NATURAL RESISTANCE TO THE
VIRUS AND COULD EVEN CARRY IT
WITHOUT SYMPTOMS.
>> THERE MAY BE A
DISPROPORTIONAL INFECTIONS AMONG
THAT GROUP, EVEN IF IT’S A RARE
OCCURRENCE, IT MAY BE SEEN MORE
FREQUENTLY IN THAT GROUP AND TO
BE EVIDENT NOW.
>> DR. DEBORAH BIRX DEBORAH BIRX
ALSO ALERTING AMERICANS TO
PREPARE FOR A SPIKE IN THE
INFECTION NUMBERS BUT ONLY
BECAUSE A BACKLOG OF TESTS WILL
NOW BE RUN THROUGH A HIGH-SPEED
SYSTEM.
>> WE WILL SEE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE DIAGNOSED DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE OVER THE NEXT FOUR TO
FIVE DAYS.
>> SEVERAL TIMES A DAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP REFERRED TO
CORONAVIRUS AS THE CHINESE
VIRUS, HE MADE NO APOLOGIES
INSISTING HE’S ONLY TALKING
ABOUT WHERE IT CAME FROM AND
DENIED ANY RACIAL OVERTONES.
>> IS NOT RACIST AT ALL.
IT COMES FROM CHINA.
I WANT TO BE ACCURATE.
AS YOU KNOW, CHINA TRIED TO SAY
AT ONE POINT, MAYBE THEY STOPPED
NOW, THAT IT WAS CAUSED BY
AMERICAN SOLDIERS.
THAT CAN’T HAPPEN, IT’S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN, NOT AS LONG AS
I’M PRESIDENT.
IT COMES FROM CHINA.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE DEFENDANT THE
PRESIDENT ON TWITTER, SPANISH
FLU, WEST NILE VIRUS, EBOLA, AND
ZEKE I WERE ALL NAMED FOR
PLACES.
OFFICIALS SAY THEY DON’T KNOW IF
CORONAVIRUS WILL FOLLOW THE
TYPICAL SEASONALITY PATTERN
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE ENCOURAGED BY